what's up y'all this is jack harlow
check me out on the bootleg cab show
who like cab show special guest in here
this is the 99th interview he's done in
the last i don't know two weeks
i know you're [ __ ] tired bud welcome
jack harlow thank you for taking the
time out buddy thanks for having me man
i like you i like your situation there
you know we're self-made now man we
don't work for nobody we still on all
those radio stations still on a real 92
3 every night but like
power play trying buddy wonderful i feel
like this might be like the last time
you do everything if that makes sense
you're exactly right
i'm like bro you're like like you know
you're on that superstar level now so
this is probably the last time you're
gonna have to like really run the
gauntlet in terms of just like pulling
up to every single little thing i didn't
have to i wanted to no i'm saying and
that and you didn't need to either you
know what i'm saying so i think it's
dope to see like uh somebody who's
you know having a sex you're having
right now still tap in and
and just
pull up on everybody man let's do it
yeah um how's everything going man i
mean [ __ ] obviously great
yeah everything's cool bro i'm blessed
um
[Music]
focused
glad the album's out ready to
step out of the studio for a little bit
live some life so i have
some new perspective on the way back in
i just want to thank you for bringing
uh caucasian humor to the forefront of
hip-hop
because all my friends always just say
i'm suss as [ __ ] because i'd be saying
the most wildest [ __ ] i recall and uh so
it's nice to have somebody else on your
level normalizing such
humor in hip-hop i got to be me
um how was the kentucky derby man i mean
obviously it looked [ __ ] great yeah
it was a blast you were snazzy out there
thank you thank you yeah i had a great
time uh it's it's dope to
you know do these interviews and
travel the world and people want to know
how was louisville kentucky
your hometown people want to know oh how
was it in louisville they asked about
something that took place in louisville
it's beautiful um yeah i mean uh did you
get you and drake shot the like official
church churchill downs video there
we're shooting something
do you have to get like a green light
from the kentucky derby or do you just
say hey we're bringing a guy with a
camera let's just figure it out as we go
give us some some leeway they did give
you something else they let us breathe
you know they were i think they could
feel the gravity of the moment um did
you gamble at all did you put anybody
underneath a horse not a gambler but uh
i decided to lose some money
yeah because the guy who won or the
horsey one rather i guess it was like a
[ __ ] long shot right that's what
everybody's saying i could i could i
went with i went i was silly i went with
the horse named after myself it was a
horse named happy jack
i was in a good mood so i ran it if you
don't know [ __ ] about horses that's not
a bad strategy
i hate for him to come in first and i
say i bet on someone else yeah um i also
want to thank you because i'm from
phoenix and you are the only rapper of
the last like 10 years who's
twice
just given us some love in records like
i just want to say thank you for that
yeah you know what i mean shout out and
then i saw that we you know we had you
situated at a game earlier this year you
had the jersey and everything i love
phoenix and i mean that i'm not just
saying that because you're sitting here
in all the uh regalia i love phoenix and
obviously uh
you're betting on us to win the
championship right see what happens i
got some friends on that team who are
your friends on the team i'm cool with
jay and uh devon javale jay crowder yeah
um yeah some cool guys on that team man
a lot of cool dudes it's a cool team
actually super cool team yeah and then
devin went to kentucky that's right i'm
a little obviously not louisville not
the cardinals but you know in the same
state you know yeah
you know what i also thought was dope
about you as the last album
um you kind of like i know estg was
always bubbling but like i feel like you
kind of
brought him to the commercial side with
um with y'all's record um how dope is it
just to see like estg
doing his thing and just in general like
i feel like kentucky as a whole is like
really having a moment right now
yeah man it's never been like this i
always say sorry let me
take all my i'm like a father
dude it's crazy because i have
bro
i have the same amount of keys on my
[ __ ] it's kind of it's like
uncomfortable i had to get it out of my
pocket i couldn't focus those are some
dad keys for sure because i got keys
like that for sure yeah i'm fatherly man
yeah
um it's wonderful louisville's never had
a time like this and
you know
with g i was just always thought he's
one of the best rappers alive so i
wanted to collab with him him being from
the city
it's such a special bonus and obviously
a reason to work but um i give him all
the credit in the world for you know
where he's taking it you know he's made
the records and
people feel some sort of conviction from
him that i felt from the start so i
don't take any credit on g's success but
i'm really happy with what we've done
together and
going forward i'm sure we'll do more but
i'm very proud of him 100
uh you got to do a leap of record which
is uh obviously i saw that you had
gotten kind of like ran it by her before
it came out because that'd be kind of a
random thing to just drop a song named
after and she had no [ __ ] clue yeah i
didn't want to blindside i felt like she
she seems like a um
a sweet person a nice albanian woman
yeah it's super sweet she confirmed that
when we talked i just wanted to let
just wanted to let her know and see if
she had said i don't like this it
wouldn't have came out i'll tell you
that so i just wanted to run a buyer
this album to me is like
i listened to the whole album three
times straight through i feel like
probably like
i was expecting a little bit more of a
vulnerable album from you even though
there's some vulnerable moments
based on just the name of the project
yeah
it's like you said there's there's
vulnerability in the album but i'm
having a lot of fun making the music and
i think you can hear it in the records
and a lot of the songs are
inspired by all the concerts i've been
doing over the last year
and so
i think i couldn't hide the fact that
i'm enjoying my life
and um
you know that's not a reason to shy away
from vulnerability i found my moments
for it but i had a lot of fun making
this music and
i say that genuinely because in the past
i think i've let
people's opinion affect my own
perception of my music you know i've let
how people view it i can go listen and
it can kind of reshape how i hear my own
stuff and i'm like
well it could be better
but
i think this time around like
you know maybe the whole world isn't on
the same wavelength as me in terms of
maybe they can't relate well that's how
i'm feeling by the way i mean i would
say the whole world might be because
first class i think is like what came
out was number one first week so like
point being
there's been nothing that's been said
that has been able to convince me that
this music isn't special this music is
incredibly special and i think it's
gonna age
timelessly and that's something i'm
really proud of because like i said i've
been able to be convinced in the past
i've been able to people been able to
make me doubt myself but this time
around like
i feel really good about the album like
it's my best body of work and i'm gonna
continue to grow but i'm i really love
it yeah i feel like i saw in an
interview you say that once you became
really confident and like you kind of
learned
i think you had said you could correct
me if i'm wrong but once you kind of
learn to not
force your raps and kind of be
conversational when you rap and
you know not rap at people but rap to
them that like things kind of started to
change for you yeah
like um and i feel like on this project
your confidence is just like obviously
at an all-time high you know you could
just hear it i mean you're in a
different space obviously but yeah i
mean i think the one thing is like
i'm keeping in mind that people want to
sing this music with me
you know people want to we want to do
this together it's not just about me
it's not me about me
um putting on a show necessarily as much
as it is hey let's let's do something
that we can all enjoy together and
that's something i really learned on
this album so i'm excited to hit the
road with it and i think it's gonna um i
think it's gonna continue to age
i think it's gonna age really well
what's up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks at bluechew.com
fellas
when it's time to get that [ __ ] going
you know what i'm saying when it's time
to hit the sack with a young lady you
need that confidence
trust me maybe you had a bad day maybe
your anxiety's through the roof your
stress well that could [ __ ] up
everything when it comes time for you to
get down you know what i'm saying with a
young lady or a young man whatever
you're into uh well young etc whatever
you like you know what i'm saying listen
bluechew.com is to the rescue bluechu is
a unique online service it delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in a chewable form at a
fraction of the cost and it's fire it
works trust me bluetooth tablets they
help men achieve harder
stronger [ __ ]
stronger erections
and it combats all forms of ed all right
that's right
if you're feeling a little uh like ah
man [ __ ] ain't been right down there
listen that blue chew come to the rescue
get your dick right bud all right trust
me when i say it hey listen blue chew
it's an online prescription service it's
the best part there's no weird awkward
visits awkward conversations at the
doctor's office none of that it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
all right it's super simple go to
bluetooth.com
you can consult with one of their
medical providers uh and then once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
online all right that's right
and uh the best part is you can go to
bluechew.com right now use my promo code
bootleg at checkout that's use the promo
code bootleg at checkout and you're
going to get your first month of bluechu
for free
just five dollars shipping trust me when
i say
this [ __ ] is lit all right i love blue
chew
maybe you're married
maybe you um
just going through it at work and you
just feel like you need that extra
little boost that extra confidence man
edie hits a lot of men in different ways
you know what i'm saying that blue chew
will have your dick right my g
bowman
bowman
thor's hammer
bluechu.com
get your first month for free with the
promo code bootleg asap go do that yo
let's break down your nails you got the
uh the manny popping off you know what
i'm saying with the with the clear coat
you're right how often are we are we
hitting the nail spot or do they come to
you at this point what's going on uh
they come to me
and two three times a month probably two
three times whatever is necessary do you
get your toes done i don't get them done
but i get them you know it's a nice
relaxing thing to have someone do your
feet nice little massage
it's my least favorite part when they
pull that file out oh yeah it could be
i'm just like yeah it depends on how
[ __ ] up your feet are for sure yeah
because once they get to the side and
it's almost like they're just grinding
skin off your heel yeah i'm
notorious for my nail lady for bracing
do you have like a
go-to nail lady who's just on the road
he's the best in the world
i mean he's in atlanta her name is uh
she's incredible shout out to maya from
atlanta yeah um you obviously are
getting into the acting [ __ ] which i
think everybody's want i mean
i if somebody don't bag you andrewski up
for the buddy cop film
they're crazy uh but uh congrats on
nailing the role and uh the new white
men can't jump thank you um
is this something that has always been
in the cards for you because you're a
[ __ ] you're like hilarious bro yeah
like at least to me i know some people
are like i don't know jack holla bro
that [ __ ] that i forget what everyone
agrees with you're [ __ ] hilarious bro
like was this always something that was
in the cards for you or was just like
something that just kind of naturally
happened once people really got to kind
of grasp who you were a person both
i
felt like it was not
it felt natural it arrived we didn't we
didn't ask for it
came to our doorstep and it felt right
it's been a lot of work but it's time
start tomorrow have you ever had a joke
that someone didn't let fly like you
know like their my favorite joke you did
was when you uh i think you were being
interviewed
i forgot who was it was at the drew
league thing
and you were saying i'd let you guard
the [ __ ] out of me or foul me or some
[ __ ] you what i'm trying to juice yeah
yeah that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] hilarious
but have you ever tried to get a joke
off like that to somebody and they were
just like fam nah
oh constantly it happens a lot of my
life it all depends on how um
[Music]
how tough the person is um
yeah throughout my life i mean i i'm
starting to see what genre is your
favorite
and that genre specifically
you never know what's going to happen
for sure
it's funny because i got by hobies so be
around me and you'll know when they're
around me based on like the [ __ ] that
they now laugh at or the slick [ __ ] that
they'll say yeah and i'd be like oh
be hanging around me a little bit much
bud
rubbing off a little bit that's what i
say i say that uh people can be
converted
[Music]
that's real
oh man um what about i mean obviously i
saw you just announced uh some new tour
dates yeah with the city girls shout out
to city shout out to the city girls yeah
they're going clean already so when you
say they're going clean like the city
girls are going clean no cussing on
stage what's going on what do you mean i
think they'll be cussing i mean the
shows oh the shows are selling out shows
are
by the time people hear this it's over
with it's a wrap yeah step up in the
venue size i'm assuming arenas
what is your now that you are doing
arenas
what's the green room gotta include man
what's on the rider um
i don't know we need to upgrade it man
i have no problem with nature valley but
let's go through it right now what do
you need too many nature valley bars
over the years
lots of carbs in those is it in the
nature valley bars i believe so they're
also they crumble a lot right you take a
bite and it's like i don't mind a mess
i've mastered that it's just like
i don't know it's the same [ __ ] i just
try to eat healthy but it's so bland in
there i think it's just time i'm
razzle it up a little so when people
walk in they're like wow you did level
experience yeah it needs to change
so it needs to update like i said it's
just nature valuable what are we
thinking water we think it's some oat
milk
some strawberry like chocolate
strawberry i don't know let's let's go
through it man what do you need in there
you could ask for anything in it of
course like a there gun
that's the gun with the ball at the end
yeah that kind of looks like it'd be a
wild like never mind yes that yes
and it is a wild that it is right it
kind of looks like a big-ass anal bead
that just anyway yeah
you went there love it
um yeah i want a there gun
maybe some pasta i don't know i want hot
food in there not packaged food so some
pasta we're going red sauce we're going
white sauce what are we doing i'm
assuming white sauce yeah good
assumption
you love the white sauce i love white
sauce it's not good fettuccine is good
right nothing like cream man not like
that creamy white sauce that's right
yeah
good noodles oh yeah you're getting your
ones right now
chop them up send them out
[Laughter]
wait hold on time to stop the interview
because we got to talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssoxofficial.com that's odd
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg kev at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them i wanted
to ask you man because i i do feel like
just watching your journey the last like
four or five years has been like real
dope to see just like
you know in terms of you just coming
into your own you know um and there's
something to be said about like
i guess
you know watching generation now and how
they've
you know how they're developing a guy
like seti hendrix or how they developed
you over the years like
how dope is it to know like you know
you got drama and lake and those guys in
your corner you know what i mean so dope
it's ill just to have somebody that
i can run things by and just has seen so
much i haven't seen
you know when i make decisions on my own
sometimes i feel like they're like
what the hell you don't
i don't i don't know if they even
realize how much
i value their perspective and i'm so
grateful to
have them in my side it's amazing it
feels like i'm meant to be here you know
they validate me 100
if i if like drama was my manager i
would i would have him do my voicemail
same if he was my manager i would too i
would just everything voice related i'd
try to figure out how to get his voice
on my cereal he's on the new album he's
um no i know he's i mean i just mean in
terms of just like personally no i get
it
sick flex call my phone everywhere i can
involve him it feels good because his
voice there's never a moment his voice
doesn't sound right a hundred percent um
how how like active or do you i mean
obviously you're going to tour this
album
um
you've been pretty consistent with
putting out music i feel like almost
every year at least close to it right
like
um how soon are you gonna get back in
and just cook up or is it a good
question
i don't know like i said i think i'm
gonna let it breathe for a sec you know
my goal was to really
work hard on this album and
have it change my life in the right ways
and then
take a step back so i can come back with
some something fresh you know something
more to say something something new one
of the more vulnerable records or at
least you know in my opinion was the
record with jt yeah shout out to jt
shout out big shout out jt uh that's
gotta be a bucket list thing right huge
all-time great all-time great caucasian
that jt fourth quarter some might say
jack harlow's all-time great caucasian
right yeah man i wouldn't be mad at that
um but yeah what like
so that was one of the last records like
snuck in during mastering
insane
that's crazy yeah so like
literally i mean
that song is not three weeks old like
the song is new that's crazy yeah so
what was it before was it just a
reference because obviously you had
those verses together i'm sure i mean i
did those verses late
i just love that beat and i just was
venting on it and then but it didn't
have a chorus
so we presented it to him and he laid it
down in front of me he smacked it in
front of you yeah wow was it fast like
yeah that's crazy yeah shout out to jt
man massive shout out video
we'll see
what's obviously we're going to get a
churchill's downs video
that's obvious um
i don't know it's like
we've had a couple days to see what the
fans love
and i just want to see what continues to
cook i'll probably put a feeler out to
there tomorrow say yo what do y'all want
to see if you were to shoot the duolippa
video yeah
would you guys drop the bag to have her
actually be in the video with you
because that'd be a nice i mean i feel
like that would kind of be
um the real icing on the cake
she's done i'm down
uh what are you like i feel like you
have a vast uh
i guess
taste and as far as like range what
you're into hip-hop while he's like what
are you really listening to right now
just in your free time you know what i'm
saying like
bumby came to my release party in
louisville this weekend
king of the trip just had me um
going down
listening to some ugk
that's what i was listening to yesterday
but you know when i said i want to take
a break what i want to get back to is
being a music listener being a fan again
right yeah i haven't been very good at
that while i was cooking i don't
because when i leave the studio i don't
want to hear music so i don't i don't
make it a habit you know i ride in the
car and sounds and
it's something i've been doing for years
and um
i don't know it'd be nice to get back to
listening again
yeah i feel like especially if you're in
a creative mood it's almost like you
don't want to be
influenced on accident subconsciously if
you listen too much every time i do it
influences me in a great way like got
you so it's something
it's something i don't naturally do that
i wish i naturally did because every
time i listen to music i'm like oh music
is awesome so when you're in the car
riding around usually you're riding
around in silence no podcast no sports
talk nothing
it's just silence that's right your
thoughts that's right i respect that
that's how i am my wife hates it because
i'm like i listen to [ __ ] music all
[ __ ] day my whole life revolves
around music sometimes i just want to
just sit in the [ __ ] car makes you
wonder if you love it
that's fair what else um
when
have you guys figured out when you're
filming this movie yet
tomorrow you're filming it tomorrow yeah
are you excited yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's time to get in the movie
mode that's what i mean by a step away
do they put you in with like uh i mean
obviously i'm assuming you're decent in
basketball just based on your bars um
but
uh do you like have to go get with like
a [ __ ]
trainer to get your jump shot down type
[ __ ] so you don't look crazy on on on
the movie like and if so who's the
trainer
he's uh he's a low-key guy
it's not like he's not one of them chris
brickley or nothing yeah shout out chris
so i've worked with him but no this guy
that i've been working with is a
he's a family man i'll just say that
family man normal guy just so it happens
if you go to basketball exactly great
guy too what are acting lessons like
because i'm assuming you've taken some
of those yeah i've been working with
this uh
this woman that's just brilliant
and um
she surprised me at how
exciting the lessons can be and how
connected
how connected the music is to acting how
many threads there are that make it feel
similar i don't know it's it's ill i
mean if this is gonna be anything like
the first movie you might have a rosie
perez your version of rosie perez
i have a woman in the video are you are
you excited um to get your first like
on-air makeout sessions in and [ __ ] like
that you know what i mean yes maybe
little shirtless plays
maybe a little post-sex like get up put
your basketball shorts on go hit the
[ __ ] venice beach type [ __ ] i'm
i'm looking forward to everything that's
coming with it i bet you are
well look the album is out right now man
um congratulations bro
appreciate you man yeah bro always good
to see you likewise thank you um
congrats man just [ __ ] appreciate that
yeah uh you you deserve it bro it's good
to see you brother
jack harlow ladies and gentlemen love
boom